we've been talking about the fact that  people are staying away from towns and  cities this is the scene in Trafalgar  Square a bright spring day normally full  of tourists as you can see it is  absolutely deserted these are the  streets of London at the moment still  some traffic about we know that many  people are still travelling lots of  buses you can see on the streets down  there but in terms of people on the  streets the numbers footfall tourists  shoppers are really really quiet that's  Piccadilly Circus normally really busy  this time of day lunchtime on a bright  spring morning should be full of people  but many many people obviously not  coming in to London today heeding the  government's advice to stay at home and  work from home if they possibly can